hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
right here I have razors new blade
stealth 13-inch the 2020 model this
actually has the gtx 1650 TI max q
edition and this is apple's 2020 13 inch
MacBook Pro this is the eighteen hundred
dollar model with 16 gigs of RAM 512
gigs of storage compared to the 2000
dollar model this actually has the 4k
display with 16 gigs and 512 as well so
in this video we're gonna be comparing
everything about these laptops the
keyboards the track pads the design the
ports the performance displays basically
everything to find out which one you
should be buying in 2020 so the first
thing we're gonna start off with is
comparing the size between these two if
I put them on top they're actually
really really close it seems like the
razor is just slightly wider and a
little bit less tall however if you're
looking at it from this angle you could
definitely tell that the razor is quite
a bit more thick now what I really like
about these two laptops is the unibody
aluminum design so this feels really
high quality very premium all the way
around even the hinge all metal and same
thing with the razor you got metal
basically everywhere except actually
this hinge I think yep this is actually
plastic on the hinge so the only thing
is that this black finish I don't know
if you guys can see from that camera or
from the side it's a fingerprint magnet
I'm seeing so many fingerprints and like
literally just started this video
compared to this is more resilient like
you can't tell with fingerprints as much
the MacBook definitely has a more
stealthy designed with these vents kind
of over on the edges compared to the
razor where you can see the grilles and
a thing I'm worried about with this is
is that if you're using this on your lap
I think it has a much bigger chance of
kind of overheating not getting that
good of airflow because these fans are
right here now let's go ahead and open
up these displays now the cool thing
about the razor is that it actually has
Windows hello so there you go just
logged me in just by scanning my face
which is really nice and the MacBook
just has regular touch ID now the first
thing I'm gonna do is take off these
very annoying stickers oh that does not
come off easily
either oh wow looks like you're gonna
have to like scratch this off or
something now one thing I actually
forgot to compare real quick is the
ports on the MacBook Pro on this side we
have a headphone jack and we have two
Thunderbolt three ports and on the other
side we get another two thin about three
ports now on the Razr we actually just
get one venerable three on this side
along with a regular USB a and then back
on the other side we have a regular USB
see another USB a and a headphone jacks
so you definitely get a better variety
of ports with the razor because you have
that USB a compared to just the USB C
style on the MacBook Pro but one thing
that really bugs me about the razor is
the massive bottom bezel right here like
there's so much room here it's
completely wasted they could have put in
a bigger display a different aspect
ratio maybe sixteen by ten just to get a
little bit more spacer because look at
this just huge block that's just totally
unused now I do see the point of having
a sixteen by nine display just for
gaming because this is a gaming focused
laptop so it's the best optimized for
games now let's go ahead and compare the
keyboards between these two the new
MacBook Pro has the new style of magic
keyboards so it definitely has a lot
more key travel than before it
completely destroys the little butterfly
keyboard and I like that it has the key
travel and it has a more kind of tactile
feel with more feedback than before
however using this keyboard on the razor
I don't know what what it is about it
but I really really like it I'd say I
definitely liked it more than the
MacBook it feels really good has a lot
of key travel and it definitely has a
nice amount of feedback as well now one
more thing about the MacBook is the
touch bar which it has it's different
use cases and different things you can
do with it but unfortunately a lot of
people don't really like it they'd
rather have the old function keys like
you get with the razor I personally do
not like the touch bar I'm glad that you
have a physical Escape key now but I'd
much rather have those function keys
because I hate topping around there and
sometimes it doesn't register so
physical keys are always the best in my
opinion however if we move on to the
track pads
the MacBook has the Razer beat so what's
special about these track pads is that
they basically have a glass panel and it
doesn't move at all it does not
physically click what happens is when
you press down they have sensors that
detect the pressure and there's
basically a motor that vibrates to make
it feel like it's clicking but the best
part about it is that no matter where
you click even in the corners up down
top middle anywhere it has an even
clicking feel and you could actually go
into the settings and customize the
different pressures for clicks or
anything else you'd like so definitely a
good trackpad compared to the Razer
where it has a diving board design that
traditional windows diving board design
where at the top is actually connected
so when you're trying to click it's like
incredibly hard like you have to push
pretty hard and then near the bottom
it's like just really really easy but
it's nowhere near as good as the MacBook
now let's go ahead and get into the
speaker comparison
I definitely noticed a good amount of
volume on the razor the volume was there
but everything was kind of lacking it
didn't seem like it had a very broad or
wide range of frequencies especially
lacking in the base the MacBook Pro
absolutely destroyed it in terms of base
the meds were there the volume might
have not not have been as loud as a
razor but in terms of overall sound
quality I would definitely choose the
MacBook Pro instead now while this
speaker test was running I noticed
something very interesting about the
display quality what I'm noticing is
that on the MacBook the blacks are much
deeper compared to the razor like I'm
seeing a lot of reflections I'm looking
at myself like like I'm looking at a
mirror right now because it's so much
more reflections and I think that's
because this is actually a touchscreen
display which the MacBook is not so that
might be why there's more reflections
now in terms of the quality this razor
model actually is a 4k display model so
4k resolution 60 Hertz they actually
have a 1080p 120 Hertz model for gamers
so that's definitely the option that
most gamers are going to choose this one
people might choose if they're doing
some kind of productivity work or
something else like that like video
editing photo editing because this does
have 100% srgb color accuracy now the
MacBook Pro has the hundred percent srgb
but it also has DCI p3 on top of that so
it has about 25% more colors colors
support compared to the razor now
comparing the display brightness between
the two head on it definitely looks like
the MacBook Pro is a little bit brighter
and definitely brighter than the razor
and even at maximum brightness I'm still
seeing reflections on the screen whereas
like I can't really see any reflections
on the MacBook Pro so that's a little
bit annoying even at max brightness now
before I get into performance I want to
quickly check the disk speed so let's go
ahead I have aja open right here all
right there you go Wow look at that the
razor is really impressive we've got a
almost 3000 read speed compared to
almost 2400 and about 2600 right speed
compared to 2200 so now let's go ahead
and get into the performance comparison
between these two now both these have
Intel's 10th generation processors the
MacBook actually has an i5 it's a 2.0
gigahertz I 5 now first of all I do want
to mention that I went into the battery
settings I switched it over to Best
Performance and not only that but it
also opened up the Razer synapse and I
made sure to switch it to the gaming
mode as well now one thing I do want to
mention is that you can only use gaming
mode while plugged into the power as you
can see right here if you switch over to
battery you can only get the balanced or
the battery saver now as I start these
CPU tests I do want to mention that they
both have 16 gigs of really fast lpddr4
X Ram 3733 megahertz so great on the RAM
the only downside with the razor is that
you can't upgrade to 32 like you can on
the MacBook so if you're trying to do
any kind of video editing it's a little
bit of a bummer that you don't have the
freedom to upgrade to 32 if you really
need it alright so these results are
totally unexpected even though the
MacBook Pro has an i-5 it's actually
scoring higher on the multi-core score
compared to the razor which has an i7 in
terms of the single core they're very
very similar 1237 on the MacBook
compared to 1253 but you're getting
almost 400 more points on the MacBook
Pro in terms of multi-core now on the
other hand getting into performance this
is where the razor really shines and
that's basically the whole point about
this laptop right here because it comes
with a dedicated graphics chip the gtx
1650 TI max q compared to the integrated
intel iris plus graphics on the macbook
pro so we're gonna test metal on the
MacBook and CUDA on the razor now as
this test is finishing up I do want to
mention one more thing the razor blade
does have RGB keyboard backlighting so
that is definitely a nice touch and you
you can go ahead and go into the
settings customize the different colors
or whatever you like compared to just
basic backlighting on the MacBook Pro
alright so we have our
solds and they are crazy in terms of
graphics on the map but pro we're
getting about 9900 metal score compared
to 42,000 on the razor blade stealth now
that is insane for a dedicated graphics
chip that is extremely impressive
basically what this means is that this
is a real gaming machine you can play
some awesome high-end games like Call of
Duty warzone even though that's free
that's very popular right now that I'm
actually going to be testing out that
game on this laptop I think that's the
next video we're gonna do so if you're
not already subscribed and if you don't
have notifications enable right down
there do it right now because that video
is coming soon so definitely crazy
results right here now with that I do
actually want to test out Unigine heaven
the gaming benchmark so let's go ahead
and open that and that's just gonna give
us a good idea of the differences in
gaming performance between the two all
right so I'm gonna run this test and I
do want to mention that we always use
the Xtreme preset now just by watching
the test run you could see how choppy
the MacBook Pro is compared to the Razer
definitely much better fps
so as unit in heaven is finishing up I'm
starting to hear a lot more fan noise so
definitely more fan noise on the razor
but I'm also hearing some coil whine so
it's kind of like a high-pitched noise
coming from the razor compared to a more
just fan noise on the MacBook Pro and
it's definitely louder on the razor as
well even though the GPU temp is about
65 compared to 69 there so it looks like
Unigine haven't just finished on the
razor 40 5.3 FPS that is excellent for a
thin and light gaming laptop 13-inch
compared to 13 point 5 FPS on the
MacBook Pro so obviously this cannot
handle games maybe like the lightest
games out there apple arcade or
something but definitely not like
regular nice high-end games so really
impressive performance on the razor now
if you do want to do some gaming on the
MacBook Pro may be using boot camp to
install Windows 10 we definitely
recommend hooking it up to an e GPU
system with the 50s
100 XT we actually have a couple of
videos where we did that and we got
really good fps and gaming so definitely
check that out
after this video now the final
performance tests I want to run is
Cinebench R 20 the stress test where it
basically puts a 100% load on the
processors to see how the cooling
systems handle it and what kind of
scores were going to get so let's go
ahead and run the test all right so the
MacBook Pro just finished first and I
noticed while the test was going both
were maxed out on the fans I definitely
heard that coil noise from the razor and
it seemed like the razor kind of slowed
down over time like it had a good start
but it slowed down now we got 1656 on
the MacBook Pro which is interesting
because we actually got a maximum score
of 1911 I think that was with it
unplugged I think it actually performs a
little bit worse when plugged in but
that is still an excellent score and we
got twelve seventy on the razor which
doesn't make sense that difference 1272
1656 that's actually substantial and
when you're thinking about I 5 versus i7
you're gonna think that the i7 is more
powerful but that's actually not the
case so the processor performance
definitely goes to the MacBook Pro and
it seems like the razor is more graphics
focused for gaming or maybe some
productivity like video editing now the
last thing I do want to mention before
we get into our conclusion is the
battery life now this is the 4k version
of the razor and especially when you
turn on the better performance and you
turn on the gaming mode what's gonna
happen is that you're not gonna get as
good of battery life as you're gonna get
with the MacBook Pro maybe you'll get
around five five six hours compared to
about seven eight hours in the member
pro but obviously it depends on what
you're doing if you're playing a game
with it not plugged in it's gonna die
pretty quickly or if you're doing very
high-end video editing it's gonna die so
on average the MacBook Pro is gonna get
better battery life now let's go ahead
and answer the final question which
laptops should you buy in 2020 well I'd
say the razor is more focused for gaming
because of the better graphics
performance and because it has that
sixteen by nine display I don't think
it's going to be good for productivity
even though
is gonna perform pretty well in video
editing the display is just so limiting
being so small and having that bottom
bezel of course the keyboard is
definitely really nice so if you're
doing typing you're definitely gonna
have a good experience with that but in
terms of the speaker's the trackpad
other things like that the MacBook Pro
is definitely going to be the winner
there so in terms of productivity by the
MacBook Pro especially if you want Mac
OS but if you love Windows 10 and you
want to do so gaming definitely go with
the Razer Blade stealth 13-inch so there
you guys have it hopefully you guys
enjoyed this comparison if you did go
ahead and comment down below with your
thoughts on this video and go ahead and
check out the other videos we have right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]